who doesn't like fractals
they're a beautiful blend of simplicity
and complexity often including these
infinitely repeating patterns
programmers in particular tend to be
especially fond of them because
it takes a shockingly small amount of
code to produce images that are way more
intricate than any human hand ever could
hope to draw
but a lot of people don't actually know
the definition of a fractal
at least not the one that benoit
mandelbrot the father of fractal
geometry had in mind
a common misconception is that fractals
are shapes that are perfectly
self-similar
for example this snowflake looking shape
right here called the vine coke
snowflake
consists of three different segments and
each one of these is perfectly
self-similar
in that when you zoom in on it you get a
perfectly identical copy of the original
likewise the famous sierpinski triangle
consists of three smaller
identical copies of itself and don't get
me wrong self-similar shapes are
definitely beautiful
and they're a good toy model for what
fractals really are but mandelbrot had a
much broader conception in mind
one motivated not by beauty but more by
a pragmatic desire to model nature in a
way that actually captures roughness
in some ways fractal geometry is a
rebellion against calculus
whose central assumption is that things
tend to look smooth if you zoom in far
enough
but mandelbrot saw this as overly
idealized or at least
needlessly idealized resulting in models
that neglect the finer details of the
thing that they're actually modeling
which can matter what he observed is
that self-similar shapes give a basis
for modeling the regularity in some
forms of roughness
but the popular perception that fractals
only include perfectly self-similar
shapes
is another over-idealization one that
ironically goes against the pragmatic
spirit of fractal geometry's origins
the real definition of fractals has to
do with this idea of fractal dimension
the main topic of this video
you see there is a sense a certain way
to define the word dimension
in which the sierpinski triangle is
approximately 1.585 dimensional
that the von koch curve is approximately
1.262 dimensional
the coastline of britain turns out to be
around 1.21 dimensional
and in general it's possible to have
shapes whose dimension is any positive
real number
not just whole numbers
i think when i first heard someone
reference fractional dimension like this
i i just thought it was nonsense right i
mean mathematicians are clearly just
making stuff
up dimension is something that usually
only makes sense for natural numbers
right a line is one dimensional a plane
that's two-dimensional
the space that we live in that's
three-dimensional and so on
and in fact any linear algebra student
who just learned the formal definition
of dimension
in that context would agree it only
makes sense for counting numbers
and of course the idea of fractal
dimension is just made up
i mean this is math everything's made up
but the question is whether or not it
turns out to be a useful construct for
modeling the world
and i think you'll agree once you learn
how fractal dimension is defined
it's something that you start seeing
almost everywhere that you look
it actually helps to start the
discussion here by only looking at
perfectly self-similar shapes
in fact i'm going to start with four
shapes the first three of which aren't
even fractals
a line a square a cube and a sierpinski
triangle
all of these shapes are self-similar a
line can be broken up into two smaller
lines
each of which is a perfect copy of the
original just scaled down by a half
a square can be broken down into four
smaller squares
each of which is a perfect copy of the
original just scaled down by a half
likewise a cube can be broken down into
eight smaller cubes again each one is a
scaled down version by one half and the
core characteristic of the sierpinski
triangle
is that it's made of three smaller
copies of itself and the length of the
side of one of those smaller copies
is one half the side length of the
original triangle
now it's fun to compare how we measure
these things we'd say that the smaller
line is one-half the length of the
original line
the smaller square is one-quarter the
area of the original square
the smaller cube is one-eighth the
volume of the original cube
and that smaller sierpinski triangle
well we'll talk about how to measure
that in just a moment
what i want is a word that generalizes
the idea of length
area and volume but that i can apply to
all of those shapes and more
and typically in math the word that
you'd use for this is measure
but i think it might be more intuitive
to talk about mass
as in imagine that each of these shapes
is made out of metal
a thin wire a flat sheet a solid cube
and some kind of sierpinski mesh
fractal dimension has everything to do
with understanding how the mass of these
shapes changes
as you scale them the benefit of
starting the discussion with
self-similar shapes is that it gives us
a nice clear-cut way to compare masses
when you scale down that line by one
half
the mass is also scaled down by one half
which you can viscerally see
because it takes two copies of that
smaller one to form the whole
when you scale down a square by one half
its mass is scaled down by one fourth
where again you can see this by piecing
together four of the smaller copies to
get the original
likewise when you scale down that cube
by one half the mass is scaled down by 1
8 or one-half cubed because it takes
eight copies of that smaller cube to
rebuild the original
and when you scale down the sierpinski
triangle by a factor of a half
wouldn't you agree that it makes sense
to say that its mass goes down by a
factor of
one third i mean it takes exactly three
of those smaller ones to form the
original
but notice that for the line the square
in the cube the factor by which the mass
changed is this nice clean
integer power of one-half
[Music]
in fact that exponent is the dimension
of each shape
and what's more you could say that what
it means for a shape to be for example
two-dimensional what puts the two in two
dimensional
is that when you scale it by some factor
its mass is scaled by that factor raised
to the second power
and maybe what it means for a shape to
be three dimensional
is that when you scale it by some factor
the mass is scaled by the third power of
that factor
so if this is our conception of
dimension what should the dimensionality
of a sierpinski triangle be
you'd want to say that when you scale it
down by a factor of one-half
its mass goes down by one-half to the
power of
whatever its dimension is and because
it's self-similar we
know that we want its mass to go down by
a factor of one-third
so what's the number d such that raising
one-half to the power of d
gives you one-third well that's the same
as asking
2 to the what equals 3 the
quintessential type of question that
logarithms are meant to answer
and when you go and plug in log base 2
of 3 to a calculator
what you'll find is that it's about
1.585
so in this way the sierpinski triangle
is not one-dimensional even though you
could define a curve that passes through
all its points
and nor is it two-dimensional even
though it lives in the plane
instead it's 1.585 dimensional and if
you want to describe its mass
neither length nor area seem like the
fitting notions
if you tried its length would turn out
to be infinite and its area would turn
out to be zero
instead what you want is whatever the
1.585 dimensional analog
of length is here let's look at another
self-similar fractal the von koch curve
this one is composed of four smaller
identical copies of itself
each of which is a copy of the original
scaled down by one third
so the scaling factor is one-third and
the mass has gone down by a factor of
one-fourth
so that means the dimension should be
some number d so that when we raise
one-third to the power of d it gives us
one-fourth
well that's the same as saying 3 to the
what equals 4
so you can go and plug into a calculator
log base 3 of 4
and that comes out to be around 1.262
so in a sense the von koch curve is a
1.262 dimensional shape
here's another fun one this is kind of
the right angled version of the koch
curve
it's built up of eight scaled down
copies of itself where the scaling
factor here is one-fourth
so if you want to know its dimension it
should be some number d
such that one-fourth to the power of d
equals one-eighth
the factor by which the mass just
decreased
and in this case the value we want is
log base 4 of 8
and that's exactly 3 halves so evidently
this fractal is precisely 1.5
does that kind of make sense it's weird
but it's all just about scaling and
comparing masses while you scale
and what i've described so far
everything up to this point is what you
might call
self-similarity dimension it does a good
job making the idea
of fractional dimensions seem at least
somewhat reasonable but there's a
problem
it's not really a general notion i mean
when we were reasoning about how a
masses shape should change
it relied on the self-similarity of the
shapes that you could build them up from
smaller copies of themselves
but that seems unnecessarily restrictive
after all
most two-dimensional shapes are not at
all self-similar
consider the disc the interior of a
circle we know that's two-dimensional
and you could say that this is because
when you scale it up by a factor of two
its mass proportional to the area gets
scaled by the square of that factor
in this case four but it's not like
there's some way to piece together four
copies of that smaller circle to rebuild
the original
so how do we know that that bigger disk
is exactly four times the mass of the
original
answering that requires a way to make
this idea of mass
a little more mathematically rigorous
since we're not dealing with physical
objects made of matter
are we we're dealing with purely
geometric ones living in an abstract
space
and there's a couple ways to think about
this but here's a common one
cover the plane with a grid and
highlight all of the grid
squares that are touching the disk and
now count how many there are
in the back of our minds we already know
that a disk is two dimensional
and the number of grid squares that it
touches should be proportional to its
area a clever way to verify this
empirically
is to scale up that disc by some factor
like two and count how many grid squares
touch this new scaled up version
what you should find is that that number
has increased approximately
in proportion to the square of our
scaling factor which in this case means
about four times as many boxes
well admittedly what's on the screen
here might not look that convincing
but it's just because the grid is really
coarse if instead you took a much finer
grid
one that more tightly captures the
intent we're going for here by measuring
the size of the circle
that relationship of quadrupling the
number of boxes touched when you scale
the disk by a factor of two
should shine through more clearly i'll
admit though that when i was animating
this i was surprised by
just how slowly this value converges to
4.
here's one way to think about this if
you were to plot the scaling factor
compared to the number of boxes that the
scaled disk touches
your data should very closely fit a
perfect parabola
since the number of boxes touched is
roughly proportional to the square of
the scaling factor
for larger and larger scaling values
which is actually equivalent to just
looking at a finer grid
that data is going to more perfectly fit
that parabola
now getting back to fractals let's play
this game with the sierpinski triangle
counting how many boxes are touching
points in that shape
how would you imagine that number
compares to scaling up the triangle by a
factor of 2
and counting the new number of boxes
touched
well the proportion of boxes touched by
the big one to the number of boxes
touched by the small one
should be about three after all that
bigger version is just built up of three
copies of the smaller version
you could also think about this as two
raised to the dimension of the fractal
which we just saw is about 1.585
and so if you were to go and plot the
scaling factor in this case
against the number of boxes touched by
the sierpinski triangle
the data would closely fit a curve with
the shape of y equals
x to the power 1.585 just multiplied by
some proportionality constant
but importantly the whole reason that
i'm talking about this is that we can
play the same game with
non-self-similar shapes that still have
some kind of roughness
and the classic example here is the
coastline of britain
if you plop that coastline into the
plane and count how many boxes are
touching it
and then scale it by some amount and
count how many boxes are touching that
new scaled version
what you'd find is that the number of
boxes touching the coastline
increases approximately in proportion to
the scaling factor
raised to the power of 1.21
here it's kind of fun to think about how
you would actually compute that number
empirically
as in imagine i give you some shape and
you're a savvy programmer
how would you find this number
so what i'm saying here is that if you
scale this shape by some factor
which i'll call s the number of boxes
touching that shape
should equal some constant multiplied by
that scaling factor
raised to whatever the dimension is the
value that we're looking for
now if you have some data plot that
closely fits a curve that looks like the
input
raised to some power it can be hard to
see exactly what that power should be
so a common trick is to take the
logarithm of both sides
that way the dimension is going to drop
down from the exponent and will have a
nice clean linear relationship
what this suggests is that if you were
to plot the log of the scaling factor
against the log of the number of boxes
touching the coastline
the relationship should look like a line
and that line should have a slope equal
to the dimension
so what that means is that if you tried
out a whole bunch of scaling factors
counted the number of boxes touching the
coast in each instant
and then plotted the points on the log
log plot
you could then do some kind of linear
regression to find the best fit line to
your data set
and when you look at the slope of that
line that tells you the empirical
measurement for the dimension of what
you're examining
i just think that makes this idea of
fractal dimension so much more real and
visceral compared to abstract
artificially perfect shapes
and once you're comfortable thinking
about dimension like this you
my friend have become ready to hear the
definition of a fractal
essentially fractals are shapes whose
dimension is not an integer
but instead some fractional amount
what's cool about that is that it's a
quantitative way to say that they're
shapes
that are rough and that they stay rough
even as you zoom in
technically there's a slightly more
accurate definition and i've included it
in the video description
but this idea here of a non-integer
dimension
almost entirely captures the idea of
roughness that we're going for
there is one nuance though that i
haven't brought up yet but it's worth
pointing out
which is that this dimension at least as
i've described it so far using the box
counting method
can sometimes change based on how far
zoomed in you are
for example here's a shape sitting in
three dimensions which at a distance
looks like a line in 3d by the way when
you do a box counting
you have a 3d grid full of little cubes
instead of little squares but
it works the same way at this scale
where the shape's thickness
is smaller than the size of the boxes it
looks one-dimensional
meaning the number of boxes it touches
is proportional to its length
but when you scale it up it starts
behaving a lot more like a tube
touching the boxes on the surface of
that tube and so
it'll look two-dimensional with the
number of boxes touched
being proportional to the square of the
scaling factor
but it's not really a tube it's made of
these rapidly winding little curves
so once you scale it up even more to the
point where the boxes can pick up on the
details of those curves
it looks one-dimensional again with the
number of boxes touched
scaling directly in proportion to the
scaling constant
so actually assigning a number to a
shape for its dimension
can be tricky and it leaves room for
differing definitions and differing
conventions
in a pure math setting there are indeed
numerous definitions for dimension
but all of them focus on what the limit
of this dimension is
at closer and closer zoom levels
you can think of that in terms of the
plot as the limit of this slope
as you move farther and farther to the
right so for a purely geometric shape to
be a genuine fractal
it has to continue looking rough even as
you zoom in infinitely far
but in a more applied setting like
looking at the coastline of britain
it doesn't really make sense to talk
about the limit as you zoom in more and
more
i mean at some point you'd just be
hitting atoms instead what you do is you
look at a sufficiently wide range of
scales from very zoomed out up to very
zoomed in
and compute the dimension at each one
and in this more applied setting
a shape is typically considered to be a
fractal only when the measured dimension
stays approximately constant even across
multiple different scales
for example the coastline of britain
doesn't just look 1.21 dimensional at a
distance
even if you zoom in by a factor of a
thousand the level of roughness is still
around 1.21
that right there is the since in which
many shapes from nature
actually are self-similar albeit not
perfect self-similarity
perfectly self-similar shapes do play an
important role in fractal geometry
what they give us are simple to describe
low information examples of this
phenomenon of roughness roughness that
persists at many different scales and at
arbitrarily close scales
and that's important it gives us the
primitive tools for modeling these
fractal phenomena
but i think it's also important not to
view them as the prototypical example of
fractals
since fractals in general actually have
a lot more character to them
i really do think that this is one of
those ideas where once you learn it
it makes you start looking at the world
completely differently what this number
is what this fractional dimension gives
us is a quantitative way to describe
roughness
for example the coastline of norway is
about 1.52 dimensional
which is a numerical way to communicate
the fact that it's way more jaggedy than
britain's coastline
the surface of a calm ocean might have a
fractal dimension only barely above two
while a stormy one might have a
dimension closer to 2.3
in fact fractal dimension doesn't just
arise frequently in nature
it seems to be the core differentiator
between objects that arise naturally
and those that are just man-made
[Music]
you